she's my cherry pie cool drink of water
such a sweet surprise tastes so good
make a grown man cry sweet cherry pie
hello everyone
[Laughter]
how are you guys doing today as you guys
can tell i'm in much better spirits i'm
still a little nasally but i'm in much
much better spirits also for a couple
reasons one because i get to see an
early screening of spiderman no way home
this weekend for the press junket which
is gonna be cool so i get to interview
the cast no idea who i'm gonna interview
yet and two i have a theory about
spider-man no way that i'm gonna talk
about over a geek culture explained
probably on wednesday so here's the
thing let us continue with our
discussion on spider-verse specifically
where we picked off with last time when
i left you guys on a massive cliffhanger
which was verna of the inheritors
basically going after miles morales the
ultimate spider-man now as soon as this
happens you immediately are met by the
arrival of assassins spider-man and
spider-punk right punk rock spider-man
but these guys basically show up and
they're able to fight off verna and her
forces pretty quickly and then of course
they immediately recruit miles as well
as jessica drew from the ultimate
universe and we'll talk about her here
in a second but one of the funny things
about this is that miles recognizes
superior spider-man and he recognizes
him from the events of cataclysm well
technically it was cataclysm the
ultimate's last stand and miles morales
only saw superior spider-man for like
two seconds while he was trying to
escape the baxter building in the main
marvel universe when they were time
displaced to an alternate reality after
wolverine broke time and age of ultron
there was a lot that happened in
cataclysm the important thing is miles
morales didn't know that was superior
spider-man he thought it was just
regular peter parker wearing a different
costume in a better costume but the
important thing here is that because
they're basically on the verge of death
this leads to miles and jessica drew
basically going alongside superior
spider-man and everybody else now at
that point you switch over to earth 13.
this is something i want to clarify for
everybody because of something that
seemed to throw people off in the last
few videos that we did and this is
largely my fault for not making this a
little clearer what you have here are
basically two teams of spider-man that
by and large don't seem to be aware of
the other that you've got superior
spider-man and his team and then you've
got this team that grabbed peter parker
and have him in the safe zone for earth
13. so that's something that i wanted to
sort of explain here now the other thing
that goes on is again we'll kind of
explain this as we go forward into the
future of the spider-verse event but one
of the things that's going on here is
that again they refer to peter parker as
basically their chosen one and this is
for a couple different reasons but the
most significant reason is because he's
the only spider-man across the entirety
of the multiverse seemingly that's faced
off against an inheritor and not only
lived but actually killed them remember
more luns died a couple times at the
hands of spider-man and so because of
that he's kind of like the guy that
they're really picking to sort of lead
them into the whole thing because he
seems to be the one to actually know how
to win now while all that's going on you
of course have cindy moon and again
because of the fact that she's the bride
is part of the spider totems again we'll
explain that uh in future videos that
what happens is she actually kind of
pokes around at these different versions
of peter parker and the reason why is
because as we discussed again in a
previous video peter parker from the
main marvel universe gives off a kind of
scent a sort of pheromone that draws
cindy moon to him and so the two of them
just can't stop knocking boots and so
cindy moon's question is if she's in
close proximity to other spider-man will
it have the exact same effect in the end
it doesn't really seem to be the case
that she does pick up on pheromones and
there is some general level of
attraction but dance slot doesn't really
differentiate between her just kind of
being like i mean that version of peter
parker is hot and her just kind of being
like i need to get with them right
because of like the pheromones and all
that kind of stuff the other part of
this is that with the team becoming
aware of the fact that there is a second
team of spider-man out there their goal
is to bring them to this universe
because remember earth 13 is home to
cosmic spider-man basically a version of
peter parker with the power cosmic the
enigma force right he never lost it in
this universe like he did in the main
marvel universe and one of the things
that's been established here is that
because this version of peter parker has
so much power the inheritors would be
foolish to come here and to basically
start a conflict and so in a lot of ways
they're literally in just like this
giant steel vault right where they're
basically safe from the inheritors the
other spider team it's like they're
hiding out in a hut made of straw right
i mean it's only a matter of time before
the inheritors find them and when they
do they'll overpower all of them
especially if the inheritors show up in
a large number and so you basically end
up seeing the group splitting off into
teams now there's a couple things that
happen here one cindy moon is told to
stay put just because of the concern
being that with her having her
pheromones and all that kind of stuff
that it could lead the inheritors to
them and again that ties into the nature
of the totems but the other part is
peter parker doesn't want spider-gwen to
go because as you guys know gwen stacy
died in his universe and so in a lot of
ways it's kind of peter parker just not
wanting to relive the death of gwen
stacy one of those things where he
almost kind of believes in like
predestination that like gwen stacy
across the multiverse is destined to die
he doesn't really say it that that's the
case you know we're not really even told
that's the case in all honesty the
continued existence of gwen stacy seems
to fly in the face of that but because
of the fact that it was a huge ordeal
for him he doesn't want to have to
experience that again let alone put her
in jeopardy if he doesn't need to and so
what ends up happening is you basically
switch over to the team of superior
spider-man when all the other spider-men
emerge now here's an important thing to
understand as soon as peter parker from
the main marvel universe shows up here
he immediately recognizes superior
spider-man but he doesn't say anything
right so superior spider-man does not
know this is peter parker who gets his
body back at a future point in time at
this point superior spider-man is just
kind of operating under the idea that he
will basically be spider-man forever
right or until his body gives out and he
dies whatever it is but he doesn't
really have to worry about losing his
body again to peter parker more so than
that what ends up happening is that
superior spider-man had actually
developed a device that basically masked
their scent from the inheritors so the
inheritors could show off on this world
and unless they're able to physically
locate the individual spider-man under
the protection of superior spider-man
they would never be found the problem
here is that this device is designed to
protect a particular number of people it
only has so much power to it with all
these other spiderman showing up here it
overrides the whole thing that combined
with the fact that cindy moon ignores
her orders and shows up in this universe
is basically ringing the dinner bell
right it's like giant purple letters
across the multiverse telling the
inheritors hey we're all here and the
inheritors just come pouring in right i
mean really it's only deimos who shows
up here but demo shows up and starts
attacking everybody now here's a big
difference when it comes to superior
spider-man one of the things that we
covered when we initially covered his
run one of the things that was made
apparent to us by dan slott is he does
not mess around that he is meticulous
when it comes to battle strategy and the
reason why is because dr octopus is so
incredibly intelligent and we'd have to
believe that when he began to realize
that spider-man from across the
multi-universe were being tracked down
and killed by the inheritors it wasn't
enough to assemble a team he also had to
have some kind of battle strategy for
what they could do when they faced off
against the inheritors because we saw
them fight against some of the
inheritors and they were overwhelmed
pretty quickly but as always dr octopus
learned from his mistakes and then went
forward from there and so that's why you
see him basically barking orders at
these different spidermen to attack in
different ways and by and large while
they don't necessarily get the upper
hand on damos they do exactly what they
were supposed to do which was create an
opening whereby superior spider-man
could deliver the killing blow and he
succeeds he kills damos right he kills
one of the inheritors and that's kind of
the funny thing because right off the
bat the response to that is something's
wrong that this body should have
basically broken down it's peter parker
who recognizes it right in the various
conflicts that he's had and the times
when more lun has died his body has
dissolved and so that's one of the big
questions is why hasn't the body of
damos broken down here now of course the
response and really this is actually
something that's noticed by miguel
o'hara that there's what's basically a
stasis charge that what had happened is
dr octopus had augmented his weaponry in
the superior spider-man suit with 2099
technology and so what this is basically
done is it's put the body of deimos in a
kind of stasis and so what this means is
they can take the body and then
literally analyze it study it they can
learn how the physiology of the
inheritors work which is probably one of
the best possible things they could have
at their disposal right they can find a
weakness they can reverse engineer how
their powers work and find a way to
prevent the inheritors from siphoning
off the life force of the spiderman
themselves there's any number of ways
they can approach this now the other
thing about that is that peter parker is
not a fan of superior spider-man killing
demos now again this to a degree is kind
of the naive nature of peter parker that
if this was just some random criminal
out there sure i guess an argument could
be made but you're literally talking
about a force of beings that are
tracking them down and that unless
they're killed or stopped incapacitated
in some way they will never stop they
will always come after them and so this
is one of those circumstances where the
only way to stop them is to kill them
but the other big problem is they
realize that the scent of of cindy moon
of silk is basically more potent than
any of the other spiderman here or at
least that seems to be the case and so
for the most part they are all kind of
grasping at straws and it's one of the
things that old man spider says right we
don't really know the identity of this
guy we simply know they refer to him as
old man we'll find out who he is here in
a minute but he basically says like it
doesn't matter what any of you believe
you're fumbling around in the dark you
have no idea what's actually happening
but i need to explain it to you but in
typical comic book fashion
[Laughter]
this guy's killed not only is he killed
he's killed by damos and so what we end
up finding out here is that the
inheritors have found a way to calm
themselves that in order to ensure that
they won't be killed in any one
particular universe basically learning
the lessons of what happened to morlun
they send what are essentially cloned
bodies of themselves out into the
multiverse in order to track down and
kill these various spider-men so that if
one of these inheritors are killed a
clone takes their place so they never
have to worry about actually dying off
as a race it's a genius maneuver it's an
incredibly intelligent thing to do and
so with the other inheritors showing up
as well basically totaling in three the
only thing these spider-men can do is
run and so they actually start breaking
off into groups the first group that
breaks off is ben reilly one of the
clones of peter parker from an alternate
reality and kane the clone of peter
parker from the maine marvel universe
along with jessica drew who's a clone of
peter parker from the ultimate universe
they break off to go try to find the
clone factory where it is these
inheritors are being created other
members of the spider-man team start
breaking off as well right you've got
jessica drew you've got cindy moon they
break off and do their thing they kind
of start splitting into factions right
spiderman war actually ends up going
with them this was basically marvel just
kind of splitting the team off in order
to launch tie-in comics which we will
cover in fact we'll transition to one of
those here in a second but what you
actually end up learning here as as
peter parker begins to make his escape
and miles morales of course goes through
and all that kind of stuff that he's
stopped by old man spider who actually
turns out to be ezekiel from an
alternate reality now again ezekiel was
the one who first introduced peter
parker in the maine marvel universe to
everything involving the inheritors in
the first place that the inheritors
existed they were tracking down
spider-man all that kind of stuff right
all that work that j michael cerzinski
did that led into the run of dan's slot
and this spider-verse event it all
harkens back to the original ezekiel
this version of ezekiel is from a
reality where moreland successfully
killed that universe's version of peter
parker and so he basically don the
spider-man costume or at least some
variation of it in order to carry on the
legacy of peter parker but what he says
and what he does is kind of give him not
really a list of names so much as a list
of titles he says the scion the other
the bride they're all that matter these
individuals have to be kept safe that's
something that i want you guys to keep
in the back of your head but of course
again what this does is it leads to us
basically following the clones
themselves right following jessica drew
following ben reilly and kane now again
jessica drew is basically a clone of
peter parker from an alternate universe
from the ultimate universe and in all
honesty she's basically black widow by
all standards of measurement right like
the ultimate universe version of that
character and now that i think about it
i feel like that does deserve a little
bit of explanation so the way this
worked in the ultimate universe is you
did have a natasha romanoff you did have
a black widow it turned out that in
ultimates to issues 10 through 13 that
she was actually a traitor and she ended
up basically assisting the liberators
kind of like this invading group to
topple the united states which for the
most part they were successful in doing
as payback for the united states
basically toppling the soviet union
ultimately she was injured by iron man
and then she was killed in ultimates to
issue number 13 by hawkeye and so really
it was more young ultimates than
anything else but technically it first
happened in all new ultimates vol 1. she
donned the moniker of black widow and
then went forward from there it was a
way for marvel to kind of move her away
from being like the clone of peter
parker in the ultimate universe to
basically having like her own identity
and her own character it was cool for
what it was i didn't really care what
moniker she had i just loved the
character in general but uh all these
guys or at least the three of them
basically show up in this this alternate
universe here and once they get in there
what they're expecting because it seems
to be the home world of the inheritors
at least from where they're coming from
what they're expecting is basically this
this kind of earth where like it's fire
and brimstone and they've conquered
everything and all that kind of stuff
but when they get out there what they
find is that it actually looks kind of
like a utopia like a technological
utopia and it's kind of a crazy thing
because of course with kane the scarlet
spider he doesn't really need to hide
himself per se because he's got a suit
that basically makes him invisible but
for jessica drew and ben reilly if they
go swinging through what is supposed to
be the homeworld of the inheritors the
race of beings that are trying to kill
them
they'll do nothing but draw attention to
themselves right and so right off the
bat they're like okay we need to
basically hide and so of course they end
up donning some smocks from hospitals
right so basically hospital garb with
their their back ends hanging out which
is always the most embarrassing thing
ever but as they get in there you end up
finding out that this world is basically
ruled by genix now genix is a member of
the inheritor race but he's more of like
the scientific member of the inheritor
race right like they're their main
science guy the other thing that's also
discovered here is that while they're
making their way through this building
they end up seeing all these individuals
who are essentially clones and they're
really in like a very docile state with
genex on a screen talking about how you
are elegant you're a part of a big
complex system different things along
those lines we're not really given a lot
of information insofar as how this world
functions at least at the moment instead
they end up drawing the attention of one
of the science guys who's actually this
reality's version of max model the guy
who leads horizon labs in the main
marvel universe and is actually a kind
of well i wouldn't say father figure but
very much a mentor for peter parker they
end up getting his attention and then in
turn everything starts to pop off right
they basically web this guy up their
cover's blown and they take off now at
that point because of the fact that
they're basically encountering like you
know security and all that kind of stuff
they have to read on their suits and the
jig is up right like everybody knows
that like spider-man are here now and
that of course leads to the arrival of
iron man which is a crazy thing to see
that in this universe iron man exists
and it's one of the things that's very
easy to forget when it comes to the
inheritors they don't really they have
no desire to kill like iron man or like
captain america or any of those guys
they track spider characters now if in
some alternate reality the avengers get
in the way of the inheritors trying to
kill that version of spider-man
spider-woman spider-girl whoever they'll
kill the avengers right they'll kill
whoever they need to in order to get to
their target and again that ties into
the benefit of clone bodies that if that
inheritor were killed their clone would
come back with the knowledge of how it
was they died and some means to overcome
those forces and try again the response
of iron man is basically one of
immediately attacking them now of course
they get the upper hand on him they're
able to subdue him and then in turn it
becomes a big interrogation of what iron
man knows how this world works but he's
not really dumping a whole lot of
information all he really says is that
in this reality genix basically runs the
world and that genix operates out of the
baxter building which as most of you
guys know is traditionally the home of
the fantastic four the other thing about
this and what's kind of crazy is the
question is asked like tony stark how
did you get like this and while we're
not really given a definitive answer the
explanation that's offered here is that
most likely what happened is tony stark
in this universe was probably killed and
this is a clone of that version of tony
stark that in fact most every citizen on
this planet is likely a clone designed
to be docile designed to never resist
the the control of genix himself that
genix isn't really viewed as like a god
among these people but is certainly
viewed as a person whose authority is
beyond contestation and so this again
basically leads to the clones heading
towards the baxter building now this
actually leads to a pretty genius
maneuver where you actually have them
strip tony stark of his armor and then
ben reilly dons the armor himself and
then pretends to lead them in as what
are basically prisoners it's a pretty
smart maneuver right it's a very
intelligent thing to do because when
that happens basically jessica drew
breaks free and it's like oh my gosh
she's free somebody stop her right and
then like while security's dealing with
her you have ben riley in the iron man
suit basically taking kane and then
leading him to quote unquote the prison
cells which allows jessica drew to
basically do her thing and buy them as
much time as they possibly can the
problem here is that while you would
expect ben riley in his iron man suit
and kane to be able to sort of move
through the building almost at their
leisure so long as it's being treated
like a uh like iron man escorting a
prisoner and investigate the place learn
more about the planet where they're at
where the clone factory is that's
creating these inheritor clones so they
can destroy it all that kind of stuff
they're suddenly met by the arrival of
johnny storm the human torch who is
quite lightly in this universe one of
the most powerful beings on the planet i
would even argue johnny storm is
probably one of the most powerful beings
across the marvel multiverse right that
guy he's just super powerful like johnny
storm in any universe is ridiculously
opaque but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace